you want to hit the tambourine for me
brah yeah welcome everyone to the wide
the most esteemed okay get out of the
shot it's my time I'm important do you
have a hundred million subscribers I
don't think so
oh yeah go cry get that guy out of here
I'm excited as always let's dig into it
how old fellow 19 year olds that's you
my mom is a fan of PETA by eggie and
loves to watch his videos with me for
Mother's Day I want to surprise him with
a possible appearance in a reddit video
I think that's about to happen I know
this is unlikely but I want to truly
surprises surprise
19 year old mom there you go they exist
how about that
thanks for increasing my demographics I
appreciate it very nice see this is what
I've been saying all along
I'm family friendly we have evidence at
last I hate ceilings I Spit on them it's
cheap cookie - amazing fat out I don't
understand how they kicked out and keep
getting away with it anime Netflix
adaptation okay come back you're so cute
I'm sorry
yeah Fitness and Ferb episode coming up
very soon so soon
don't worry guys very soon oh okay
another I don't know what it is that's
got Alec Dave that's cute and I look
like that okay sure why not
at least I'm taller than the low
munchkins another great very nice all
right I found the real banked know
that's that's Benny boo hey we don't
talk about him don't worry about it
don't worry about a gay big Dave's not
lost
he's on vacation in Tijuana having a
good time Pierce speaking in Japanese
while flying plane
and beginning to see a pattern here that
I'm not so sure I like it was everyone
else it was everyone else not me okay
I'm good
that's it to work no no I keep getting
hiccups when I do that boys okay okay
I'm a 19-year old carpenter and my first
job at a job site is to cover
fluorescent paper and thin plywood so
they don't get ruined basically I'm the
protector of floors floor gang a round
of applause for the heroes of our
nation's well done well done
those are some nice-looking floors not
gonna lie I'm not biased or anything but
damn you're doing a good job there
that's huge pee pee right there enormous
don't ever make a ceiling though just so
we're clear okay all right my grandma
suddenly collapses on the floor me
[Applause]
[Music]
basically I won't hurt in lived it it
was the greatest moment of my life
Pierce told us to play Minecraft and
they did it you did it you crazy son of
a B word you did it well done ten out of
ten do they sleep in the nether yeah I
did that I did that too okay we have
Calvin and Hobbes oh my god
oh my god that was my favorite comic
when I was a kid well I mean it's not
really accurate is it because you know I
heard some weird that went down that I
can't even bring up because it's Wow
holy crap you guys have been stepping it
up okay god damn I'm not gonna lie
though my eye looks kind of thick I like
it I like the drawn legs very nice dude
a green tambourine imagine a custom-made
tambourine
it looks like a movie poster very cool
very cool
pika pika mother or I'm not god damn it
you're ruining you ruin it hope you're
happy that's him that's the guy who has
a very big peepee all right I
transferred that to me to you that's how
that works
and point out you're your mom and say
big peepee
I know moms are watching all right if we
so rich how come we can't afford no
ceiling huh
that's floor game or game that's right
the greatest I'm not saying that we're
gonna kill and take everyone and take
over the world
I'm just saying yes most people I had a
dream when I dated my question my dreams
last night I had a dream where I met
Peter Pine asked him if I could take a
photo he said no I'm wearing okay and
he's so much put there Mel and Heather
said it's not bucket gang while running
what am i doing to people I'm sorry that
is usually dreams don't interest me but
that's it yeah that's that means
something maybe you're a an Oracle or
prophet or something and this might
happen that'd be sick dude if in like 30
years we're proffering melonhead's dude
that'd be sick my mom would be like
burrow maybe we switch to not buck again
no it's always flora gang it's always
been consistent it's one meme on this
channel if you're new that's always been
consistent
check out the merch I'm wearing it right
now I'm wearing it inside out that's a
cool way to do it that's the low-key
flex people I said that he will bring
back pink correct and I did I find it
finds a random fox replacing it we'd
Bengt her names at bain't well here I
was thinking I was quirky and funny huh
listen I don't make the rules I'm not
God what do you want me to do I can't
bring back the dead
I mean Bengt is fine he's fine
trust me he's totally fine we're chillin
his team Tawana me hearing Felix were
treatments team that's right everyone
check out the streams is gonna be
Thursday so tomorrow basically
3 p.m. UK time I see you guys there
I'll start early for members if your
members check out 30 minutes before and
we'll talk about all the secret stuff
like you get all the instant I out like
where is banked we're gonna watch
Phineas and Ferb know Karen's allowed
basically we can do all this stuff if
you're Karen I'm gonna ban you that's
just how it is what is this Pizza still
real no no keep getting hiccups Oh No
what the hell is happening
it's like someone's wants to come out of
there that's not a Karen haircut
and I'll let you know the ladies liked
it all right not that it matters because
I found the most bestest lady in the
world but the ladies in the past Sweden
they were like the hair would like go
down in front of my eye and I would do
that I'm not Elsa it was now I look like
this this is how it look like now this
is better faith famous people who can't
stand beauty bye wait I gotta play that
famous people who can't stay in
PewDiePie ra let me guess
Trisha Paytas no irrelevant and
disgusting well maybe she was just
looking in the mirror and got confused
Alina T doesn't fall in it of course
doesn't forget case I know no we we cool
now look I saw this video where
apparently both of us are vibing to each
other
it's very wholesome two minutes of ksi
and PewDiePie respecting each other I
can't watch it cuz I can't stand getting
compliments but I'll just give one I
think what case I was doing recently
with music and sparring he's doing good
I like seeing it keep doing it TV
producer Ekta Kapoor oh right the
dumping god alright yeah fair enough
YouTube what no no we homies now it's
all good
water under that
guys water swept under the bucket as he
say yeah yeah yeah I knew it I knew it
oh that was a brain let move I've ever
seen I was like what the hell are you
doing dumbass beer simulated it yeah
crying more you made a bad game alright
what else I don't care oh yeah that was
that Ubisoft girls right yeah I remember
I remember all of you because I will you
know I'm not saying I'm gonna hurt
anyone but if I have a tambourine and
I'm standing in front of you and you're
a hit and you have a ceiling I mean the
Viking ritual will come out you know
that's a little taste that's just a
taste of the strength
I know but never will I hurt anyone
alright let's just get this is move away
from that one let's just me things are
fine everything is fine everything is
great Peter pies live first-string be
back baby what happened to him he
crossed another bridge get it haha funny
hilarious remember that one
I don't someone made an edit that was
kind of funny cyber sent it to me even
as tired as a bridge me miss that's
right that's what happened I don't
understand what the whole fuss is about
oh my god oh my god it's not even fun
help me just I need help
can't you see I need help my other
friend trying to stop me my friend who
came with a bad idea me doing it what
the hell mark space dude I think we're
playing smash and I'm very good at it
I'm really good at smashed you're not oh
okay all right
yeah yes
I can't even replicate that's beautiful
and its own hell yeah that's humungous
PP that's I would double PP that if I
could god damn those neck those neck
yeah neck is plural right yeah okay good
all right we had the meatball deaf sorry
uh-huh okay I love democracy I think
this is smart no no no no no I did not
kill the anyone in Minecraft so you know
it's Oh God
what the hell oh wait I was sitting in
high school I created my yes okay all
right
that's insane did or Dow is ID yeah all
big peepee well that's awesome dear
that's so cool well done got a prank
fits when he comes back they won they
date a I'm coming back as soon as the
game gets updated because I already beat
it then so that would be great I look
forward to add some new more content the
entire plots of Felix my cursors started
because he killed a bunch of sheep for a
food for food in the first episode yeah
this is what we need like 20 minute
hyper analyzing every single episode
finally people are picking up on the
allegory and all the subtle hints that
I've been trying to keep in there all
the philosophy all the new one says
Felix I've been uploading consistently
for 10 years generate come on god what
have I done what have I done
no it all started with gaming week and
that's a fact
when was gaming week maybe it's time to
launch another one it needs to be like a
yearly thing alright June 3 June 25
gaming week 2.1 coming right up be ready
what has two putts and kills people an
assassin life damnit
actually work oh gosh small peepee I
don't like puns oh how cute
okay I'm sorry all right I'm sorry
you can hit the tambourine again come on
you love this thing
okay yeah yeah hit the tambourine
hey you can sit in my lap that's alright
you want to you want to sit in my lap
alright he wants to sit in my lap come
on you love sitting my lap hey I had to
go to the vet yesterday and you were
such a good boy huh yeah you want to
tell them about that good boy Oh
did it work though ha ha you see that I
got you oh you're in it never mind sorry
I'm sorry
beyond floor gang that's illegal
stop him position - name I care bird
shell bird you think you're so funny huh
that's genius
it will happen it will happen no no no
no no that's not it I have ass dude I
have a sack of 20 tables at least at
least I haven't counted them but they're
all there ready to use
I can literally beat to the ceiling
which I wore that was a test
you better get be frightened by that
vanilla versus r-tx artiest look like
garbage is garbage is garbage on yeah I
saw some post saying that you're a Kives
iron bars will do that I'll do that I
need to find a way to get her in there I
made IKEA bird out of paper
damn that looks so cute well done when I
see my own in the toilet when I see
someone else hmm
oh you're gonna go now huh all the video
isn't that entertaining huh well have
you smashed like them subscribe already
yeah that's what I thought your floor
guy yeah good if I ever catch you on the
ceiling you know you're dead right you
know you're dead it's this guy what is
this hair huh what is that
let me get this straight you think that
the
all the winter was better I do and I'm
tired of pretending it's not I don't
even remember the old one without are
you better not to this side you better
not
oh my god what if Edgar was perry the
platypus I would literally ppppp yeah
they leave it the kids minecraft well he
told me he spent a year on it and he's
crying now who cares no kids should be
so dependent of a silly game Karen yeah
I heard about this there was an article
about a dad that deleted his Minecraft
world it just it's just unforgivable
there needs to be jail for this sort of
thing what's the Boomer equivalent
that's like deleting your beer how do
you feel now it doesn't even nothing
compares damn
alright fine are people you're killing
it you're killing it absolutely huge PP
I can't our so beautiful my god welcome
to the game kid
we got stealing Steve we got murdering
Mike and dead what a dead - he deleted
his son Matt cramp up
he says goddammit psychopath who would
do such a thing huh unspeakable evil
Galleria breakfast first breakfast last
Brooklyn under mill brofist ten-year
breakfast a random breakfast how's it
goin Bros rosy brows top for worse hip
up Roshan rose Inca gran fan fan fan fan
fan fan fan
purikura purikura paint no paint it's
cool guys just give him a chance please
he's really self good conscious and he
just wants to be like please guys I have
a protagonist quickly it's not just art
in and out of sea cover for sword the
opponent
that's hilarious good meme legit good
humor everyone where it's baked bean
well he's gotta be I'm sure do you wanna
you know how it goes it's evolving just
backwards alright you mean devolving
Felix me finally do some homework it's
too much have they delivered have you
guys gone on them yet oh my god that
looks sick dude I got eyebrows now hell
yeah I like eyebrows I have those I have
two of them I'm late after you had write
it top common winced a tambourine
YouTube comments have moved everyone you
did it you made the world a worse place
congratulations crappy design yeah I
don't really get that one it's kind of
annoying
I guess they I should probably not
complain because it probably means more
people are watching more videos but hey
hey guys look who I brought the whole
pack is back together how dare you stand
where he stood don't guys please faint
it's literally he went to Tijuana
because he's crying because he saw this
table ready you called me up last night
I told them don't worry it's good like
I'm gonna tell them and they're gonna
change their mind so please reconsider
oh yeah yeah yeah merch available some
people were confused it's one percent
legit just check it out representing a
cop /pt pie if you want if not you know
you're safe and basically it's one
saying I'm up pressuring you I would
never pressure my five five dollars if
your love her brother her father your
father your sister you Alabama why do
you like Alabama huh why do you like the
frickin tank would Bank all of a sudden
you don't like can we like the same
thing for once Jesus Christ dude oh yeah
creepy that's a good guess it's close
but it's not quite there you tried you
tried your best anti wick but so far the
scoreboard on guesses is 500 in my favor
and zero none of you has got any right
none that be not a single one not even
close don't even try honestly it's
embarrassing oh god damn I made it a
pity pie temperance and I start watching
vids from 2012 and I'm actually
let's sync vlog a go dude well done
that's so cool
I love that huge huge I cannot state the
size of this pp I mean hell yeah
guys I'm watching hiking right now you
gotta watch it it's so good
my teacher watches PT I get him to see
this I forgot to do my homework
mr. McDonald's oh I that confused me so
much your teacher's name is McDonald
this is so weird
hey it's friends PewDiePie channel
transcends all ages it's because it's
like cartoons I have really clever jokes
that only the adults gets like the
peepee stuff they adults love that they
love it yes
another great fan art well done guys you
get some you get some time we're in
class today because he's a judge
alright guys thanks for watching if
you're not subscribe subscribe only 10%
of hit the bell button what they don't
five dollars actually if you wanna
become a member you get epic emos you
got a cool avatar next to your thing the
profits are going to charity each month
this month we're supporting who supports
children and young people after the
death of a parent or a sibling it's a
great charity thank you guys and as
always PP out
I'm kidding profits in the world where
science knows no boundaries travel duel
and we're no joke
bend and explore never-before-seen
landscapes encounter beings that are
extinct meet lion adverse ancestors who
collects patient items
rediscover your favorite scientifically
accurate dinos what will you create
you